[Music]
hello everybody hello hello hello how
you doing how you doing how you doing if
you're hearing my voice that means that
I'm currently on the road so I don't
know if you guys I've told you a little
bit last week we are getting ready right
now in production of the new YouTube
show last year it was Sims and left go
the show where we had one every week and
it was sort of breaking down what was
going on the NFL and doing a bunch of
skits and all that stuff this year it's
a lot more in-depth a little bit less
episodes but a lot more fun with
athletes I'm not gonna get into it all
right now we're gonna have you do like a
full promotional tour to promote it but
right now I'm on the road doing two
different shoots with two different
players so all the interviews that I did
last week at Lake Tahoe we have them for
moments like this but I cannot wait for
you guys to see the show because it's
gonna be really really fun it's taking
stuff in the NFL to a whole new left go
level so today's episode though is gonna
be Travis Kelce and Rob Riggle Travis
Kelce star Pro Bowler all-timer
for the Kansas City Chiefs expecting a
big year out of him my buddy my pal and
Rob Riggle the comedian that does a lot
of stuff with Fox NFL I'm seeing him on
ESPN right now he's a huge Kansas City
Chiefs fan and a really really good time
but first we had Kelsey who kind of came
over and look I've kind of developed a
friendship with Travis over the years
just covering them and what happens a
lot of times is you meet an athlete and
you can either connect in a professional
way and it can remain that way or you
kind of get done a conversation you're
like man I kind of [ __ ] with you and
that's kind of where I am with Travis
right now but Travis is truly one of the
good guys in the NFL he did that whole
thing where he went to someone's wedding
for the NFL he is always down to have a
good time
and I truly think that Travis is gonna
have a really big career when his when
his playing career is over he's smart he
is quick he's funny
actually this Friday night I'm gonna be
hosting his fashion show out there in
Cleveland he's got a new fashion line
called true colors with a k' that's like
kind of a bunch of different wear but
travis has a lot of different interests
and we talked about this a lot of times
on the show talking about these athletes
a lot of times they get pigeonholed as I
you only can talk about sports and for a
lot of these guys they want to do a lot
more than sports and you'll kind of see
this in the interview with Travis he's a
smart guy he's funny I've complement him
too much you know what [ __ ] Travis I'm
only kidding
but here is a nice little conversation
with Travis Kelce about the Chiefs the
first time that he started realizing
that Patrick mahomes was crazy and just
other stuff going on the NFL hears me
and I've been wanting to whisper all day
but like nobody's really been here ya
know and they're they're yelling just
about everything all day every day
you've gotten a lot of yells out of you
by the way this is Travis Kelce I'm not
mad at it I've been judging people their
fame by the level of I love it oh yeah I
love I love I feel like the last few
weeks with you has been a beautiful like
sandstorm the an MLB all-star game is in
your hometown those nuts man you're
hanging out with Drew Carey and Kelly
Price is Right baby 2zk kenny lofton man
what a guy Jim Thome I saw you that the
kids like eight years old again yeah I'm
just a kid playing ken griffey jr.
baseball on n64 that's all I am you are
you have been able to maintain who you
are better than a lot of people I've
seen I appreciate you are you are
genuinely like a grown-ass kid like I
said you do like the the wet
and all that [ __ ] but I knew you grew up
a Cleveland guy for sure to be able to
play in the Cleveland Indians Stadium I
was nuts man with the Hall of Fame
Indians guys like yes yummy tummy yummy
I don't I keep saying Jovi Tim Joe me
yeah love I mean I grew up watching Jim
told me my entire life
yes he's watching every time I say it's
okay I love a man yeah I got my the
Jersey I wore I got it signed he put
Hall of Fame 2018 Wow putting it up what
I on are there people that remind you
that this is [ __ ] crazy or do you just
hit you yeah I'm still a little kid with
yeah stuff like that
even being up here and meeting a lot of
the old-timers man it's just uh it
brings you back to like how much you
really love to do what you're doing
yeah you know I mean and then seeing
little kids and how you used to look up
to or how I still look at guys like
Jerome Bettis and Charles Woodson man
anyhow I'm looking at those guys and
Berkeley and all them like seeing those
guys little kids scream my name like
that I mean that's just
it makes life complete brother it's
awful Circle man Manville's we had a
good time with Berkeley how about that
to the final four you could you add it
to the list man sandstorm it beautiful
sandstorm take my [ __ ] phrase and
make it okay so one is beautiful
Berkeley is what like he's a my top
three guys I'd like to have a drink with
and we made that happen and it happened
not only did we make it happen we talked
about white basketball players I mean it
doesn't get better than that he gave me
he gave me a thumbs down I Bobby sir and
I all right that was a little
disappointing that hurt me that hurt me
Sora played with what other two NBA
players at Florida State
go ahead I've won won won the heisman
and then played for the Knicks Charlie
Ward and Sam get out of town those were
the three guards I fell with the Florida
State Bobby sir is that a hold yes
Kansas it's Kansas akele yeah is that
old I keep doing new things I keep doing
it I'm screwing it up every everybody's
no problem the playbook early on [ __ ]
Kansas City Chiefs bro it's feeling like
a big time like I feel like you're
hitting the stride Patty's like making
the run right now like you get Frank
Clark in there like it just feels good
Frank's a dude man that he is that he's
an absolute beast and when we played him
it was like all right yeah but we only
got one week of that I've been just
watching him go to work in practice and
that dude you'll probably change
shipping laughter yeah no I really
didn't want anything to do with him but
he he's he's a beast man just I just
appreciate how hard he works you know
that's it that's gonna change the whole
my kind of mindset of the defensive like
you know where we got some we got some
[ __ ] we got to do no doubt I do a thing
I make fun of like media stories or in
the summer I call it whoa big offseason
because usually it's like Travis Kelce
was seen doing extra sit-ups after
practice yeah they're like oh crap but
one of my woes is you wouldn't Pat have
been hanging out a lot this summer and
people are going to me and their
connection must be really strong but I
can say this for a fact you guys are
actually boys yeah pretend not every
quarterback tight end combination is
like that no no we've been pretty
fortunate to have a good understanding
of you know just where we are I mean
that's a locker room guy he grew up
around the locker we stopped playing
ball and all and he could relate to
everyone I feel like just growing up
where I grew up like I have that same
understanding being able to relate to
everyone and just appreciating the the
opportunity to be where we are in life
so Pat goes I know what it's how
specialists have a tight end like that
I'm like dude you're 23 how do you even
comprehend that
far beyond his years man yeah so there
were so many stories that came out the
year that he was behind Alex about
having practice oh yeah
were there any throws that come to mind
like that are like very visible in your
mind he would play around with the
defense I mean when you're on scout team
it's almost kind of like a jackoff
session you're just out there just yeah
I mean yeah you got to give the look and
everything but here at QB like once once
that's just you're out there playing
around my yard ball and sure enough that
dude I mean just he would be rolling out
right throw it all the way to the
opposite side line you know 80 yard
throws on the run there was a lot of
unbelievable place I mean the guys on
defense the whole time were like man I
don't understand why we don't have this
dude in here and then alex is thrown for
4,000 yards yeah this career went out
and got paid so I mean it was it was a
understanding that coaches coach Reid
kind of understood what he had sitting
in the holster but he wanted to give
Alex another shot because I think I mean
heck I still want to win one for Alex
that's my guy too but I mean since since
Pat got to Kansas City I think he was
ready his confidence is just through the
roof man it's hard to match that at such
a young age man if we let him uncork one
on a crow hop how far you think he could
do it I don't know if he's a big crow
hob guy man but the babies kind of
background that's what I'm saying I
don't know if I'm singing it just I
think he's just he's just into he's more
of a pitcher so I don't know if they're
really I don't know if there's roll out
but I 100 the mound I would say 90s a
ladies Barbara up here in a very helps
the Rockies
[Music]
yeah up here in this uh high altitude I
think he could probably get an 85 close
to 90 my high is 49 how far do you think
you could throw 74 sure really yeah I
can Huck it I can Huck it we might have
to put this to the test throw it over
those mountains I was actually up there
the other day it's a beautiful sight to
see up there I mean you've been getting
ROM and enjoying your offseason yeah I
don't tell anybody I would like to start
a campaign of making Travis Kelce the
highest paid player in the NFL you know
I represent the league in the right way
I promise you you're going to people's
weddings you're you're giving your time
to kids you're I mean I've seen you sign
400 autographs today
you sign that one baby that was
incredible man where you can in my hip
pocket is when you carried that kid in
the wheelchair up the four flights how
else was he good I mean it's just I know
just being a good Samaritan and honestly
I relate to a lot of people I live I'm a
people person that's why I'm kind of
like when someone comes up to me they're
real nervous I try and break the ice
here I mean like give me a nice ball
tapper oh no give me like that's my
because you're you're also a dad joking
all right you've given me enough time I
appreciate you know what can I ask you a
serious question
yeah for sure 33 percent the listeners
of this show I want to give them or
because when Simms left I gave his 33
percent ownership to the fans okay
because you know citizen I was like
peace bro [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
Sims II Oh gave me a [ __ ] terrible
[ __ ] read on one of these holes over
here really yeah I don't even know why I
asked but a lot of these guys they're
they're either going through [ __ ] in
their own lives or they're trying to
kind of like make the best out of it and
stuff and you're someone that can kind
of keep yourself driven you and your
brother I think both kind of live by
that a lot what would just be life
advice that you give the homies out
there that's good stuff man you know I
go by a quote and I said I kind of try
and remind myself of this whenever I'm
striving for something anything in life
really is it's not how you achieve
success not how you achieve your dreams
it's how you lead your life if you lead
your life in the right directions and
make the right decisions at the right
times your dreams will simply come to
you folks mmm-hmm shout to savor that
[ __ ] the last lecture at Carnegie Mellon
Wow Travis Kelce everybody an absolute
legend Travis Kelce always the man all
right next up Rob Riggle so let me
actually tell you how all these
interviews happened the American Century
Championships is this golf tournament in
Lake Tahoe I had never been to Lake
Tahoe this place is freakin incredible
and if you're watching on YouTube right
now
you saw the mountains behind us and the
lakes it's unreal me and Travis actually
went on the lakes later that day and I
got to drive the boat which if you're
any of my family or friends that have
seen me drive a car I purposely did not
tell them that I'm not a great driver
but they thought I was a great boat
driver and very proud of my boat driving
skills but this place is incredible
Travis actually on one of the nights
they had this event where there was a
karaoke so charles woodson goes up and
sings prince alfonso ribeiro the guy
that did carlton and fresh prince he
went up there and was rapping Jeremy
Roenick was rapping and Travis went out
there and him and his girl Kayla they
won first place which was really really
it's a cool event like man Aaron Rodgers
is golfing with Steph Curry and they're
golfing with Justin Timberlake and it's
they're having fun at night it's a
really quiet secluded area it is hard as
hell to get to Lake Tahoe we
fly to Salt Lake City and then to Reno
and then drive an hour to Tahoe and I
think that's part of the reason why it
still kept so beautiful and our makeup
artist her name was Eden we started to
realize like you got to go over and
hustle to get these interviews and
eggbert went over to get Jerry Rice and
it was an all time moment and he's not
here to defend himself but he went over
it he's like hey can I get an interview
and Jerry Rice just kept walking
so me and Eden kind of had the plan
where she would go up and go the
tournament has asked for you to
interview with Adam left go and then
they would kind of come over like she
was snagging people and one of the guys
that she kind of snagged was Rob Riggle
who I think and you'll hear me ask him
this question has a very hard job on
that Fox NFL pregame show because he's
got to do like two minutes of comedy
every week and predictions and he
somehow able to get it done but the
thing I always liked about Riggle is
he's the everyman served in the military
when in the stand-up comedy just loves
sports and you know his whole vibe of
you know face
it's he's a good dude so I really
enjoyed the conversation with him I hope
you guys do too and please slide into
his mentions as always same thing with
Travis to hit him up on Twitter DM em on
Instagram let them know that you really
liked him coming on the Left Co show and
that the 33% appreciates them hopefully
they understand what that means but
again the more you guys hit these guys
up the easier it is to get them to come
back on again and like the momentum of
the 33% right now is awesome it really
is in fact after this interview with Rob
Riggle let's let's talk a little bit
about fantasy league and then also
gambling for the season so here's Rob
Riggle and then afterwards a little news
on the 33% you got that good arm tan
right now oh yeah I was just very
jealous of Bahamas where he really yeah
you got from Shark Week no you're doing
Shark Week Rob hosting a Shark Week this
year stop it go on watch it yeah come on
did you were you a Shark Week watch by
the way as a Rob Riggle
I hosted it last year with Shaq and they
asked me to come back and do it again
this year they didn't a Shack they
didn't ask jack that's me and I said yes
and I brought Adam Devine Joel McHale
Damon Wayans and Anthony Anderson with
me and we had just an awesome time but
it was really cool we were diving with
sharks I like 20 sharks around us at
once that was like 30 feet down it was
great damn I think you have one of the
hardest jobs in sports TV which is the
Sunday Fox NFL comedy section I love you
I don't know how you guys turn that so
quickly like can you share with
everybody how that actually gets made
I haven't we've watched it for decades I
have a great group of guys Bennett
Webber who's a great comedy writer okay
and Chris PZ and myself and we go to
work every week and the thing is it's
what makes it so hard it's such a narrow
lane with which to do comedy it's it's
got to be a two-minute bit I've got to
make my picks
it can't be it has to be g-rated and it
can upset the NFL and it has to be
football centric so I can't like go do
some sketch about rap or something
that's got to be football century so
it's a narrow lane to do I think we go
into the playoffs are you talking about
18 19 weeks of that in a row yeah you're
doing musicals you're doing songs you do
it raps like I said we got a great team
and we work you know we love it we love
doing it so you do a great job well
you're very kind
Thanks Kansas City Chiefs about it let's
get excited I tried to convince my
audience right now it's Aaron Rodgers
the greatest quarterback we've ever seen
okay I petitioned that we just make the
switch already to Patrick I'm sorry
score back we've ever seen then crazy I
don't think it's crazy but like an
athletic ability I wanted him to have I
want him to have what New England had
which is that longevity you know that
Brady run where he went to nine friggin
Super Bowls and he's still not done no
you know like I want that kind of run I
think everybody everybody does and
mahomes though if he stays healthy and
we build around him we could have would
you take a course of magic mom's right
now in the armor I told you it wasn't
fatal yeah
yeah I think I would mainly because I
would do it for Kansas City for the city
we deserve it
yeah you know I'm like I'd like to super
bowl in my lifetime I love mahomes is a
great guy
Kelsey's here another great game of him
by the mahomes and Kelsey came I do a
charity event in Kansas City yeah and
they both came and saw fog
well yeah and it's a whole weekend sure
and they came and supported and we're
just so awesome to do that they they
really do care about Kansas City so
that's another reason like the city is
really embracing that as long as you
give them a homes of course ladies happy
I mean that's most guys yeah that's and
I couldn't agree more so do you do a
good Patrick moams impersonation because
that is the voice of the NFL right it is
I can't do it it's it's a Kermit which
every should be Bob you just Kermit but
also swallowing a burp at the same
connection what is it like I'm an Eagles
fan and so I got the payoff of the years
of everyone makes saying you don't have
a Super Bowl yeah how would you
celebrate do you think and do you think
you'd get it invited onto a float which
is like the big on I don't know possibly
I think you're I think if you're friends
with mahomes and Kelsey and you
represent Kansas City if I were you I
would expect to get invited on to the
flood I never expect anything but if I
did I'd be thrilled because that would
be you know that would be amazing I
would have no business being on the
float other than just being a superfan
so I'd be doing it for all the fans that
couldn't get on yeah but yeah I'm up you
know Chris peasy the guy I mentioned
sure he's an Eagles fan
so I've felt like I've been with him on
his journey it's you know when they won
I was at that Super Bowl and it was up
in Minnesota it was amazing it was one
of the great Super Bowls of all time and
I I felt very happy for him because I
know he's wanted it and the city wanted
it so bad who are I know you ant-man
there's others who are the giant city
it's sorry Paul Rudd yep Jason Sudeikis
Eric Stonestreet Dave Koechner and
myself it's a hell of a 5:00
yeah and Heidi grinder who's alive right
now she is Kansas City gal and we got a
lot of yeah there was something in the
water in Kansas City because turned out
a lot of a lot of funny people is there
a nickname for that crew mm I don't know
no not written out yet
I can't and I also the cardinal sin you
can't nickname yourself it's true you
know like a couple with one yeah okay
I'm not gonna go in there so I kind of
went in with this I like to also give my
listeners something because I have a lot
of people that we reach out for it like
life advice and stuff and a lot of
people have paths they want to emulate
your path serving in the military
serving this country coming off doing
comedy and kind of this beautiful career
that's blossoming you've been able to
pivot halfway through and a lot of
people want to [ __ ] pivot they just
they don't know or it scares them too
much how do you give confidence to
people that want to pivot you you just
said it perfectly there is a desire
people have a desire to do more than one
thing or to pivot yeah or to try
something new but their fear Trump's
their desire and until your desire
Trump's your fear you're gonna be frozen
and you're not going to do anything and
so your desire has to overcome your fear
and that means stepping out into an
uncomfortable place you know going from
the Marines to comedy yeah yeah I was
more scared on stage than I was in
Afghanistan Wow
because it's a different kind of
vulnerability it's a different kind of
it I was gonna ask if you had that fear
so like oh he went up that first time
and it was the worst my adrenaline was
going so hard that I could feel my neck
pulsing and it was like a car wreck I
don't I barely remember the first set I
ever did
thank God they videotaping it then they
gave me the videotape and I went home
and watched it and I was like oh it
wasn't that bad cuz the way I remember
it I was like this sucks
I'm out of here four seconds feels like
four oh my god yeah and so but it that's
the only way anybody's ever going to
take any action on anything you wanted
to fear go away for you oh it took a
long time it took a long time and you
know you don't have to go whole say
don't have to quit your job and go do so
I
you know I had a day job you know
sometimes you just have to have two jobs
you know it's just the way it's a day
job Marine Corps oh yeah I was doing
Marines at a job yeah but I was doing
marine quarters and then at night on my
own time I was going out and doing
comedy and then I heard I heard you say
this for one time you had a stand-up
opportunity and you were like listen I'm
going
I do not care I'm getting off the base
today and I'm gonna go and sometimes it
takes kind of like power and through
like that yeah yeah but that's the only
way people will ever ever make the move
is when they finally decide it's more
important to risk failure that's the
thing nobody wants to fail nobody wants
to be embarrassed nobody wants to be
vulnerable nobody wants to be judged but
all of those things are gonna happen if
you if you step out if you put yourself
in the arena you're gonna get the sorry
know you're a lot of [ __ ] curse [ __ ]
balls it's okay you're the man
congratulations on everything
thanks 33 percent support this man tweet
at him fill up his mentions Rob Riggle
thank you to do appreciate it dude
all right thanks again to Rob Riggle
who's really just a good guy hit him up
on Twitter at Rob Riggle r IG g lae the
two questions that I'm getting from a
lot of you guys right now are are you
still doing the fantasy league and also
what are we gonna do with the gambling
show this year so we are not ready to
fully announce but I do have we do have
some offers right now that we're hoping
to get some very cool co-hosts for
during the season some Monday Wednesday
NFL stuff
Thursday gambling stuff we're not in a
position right now it has it the dot the
line hasn't been signed the T's have not
been crossed the eyes have not been
dotted but I will announce it it will be
awesome because I got I cannot do an NFL
show during the season by myself let's
be very honest but in terms of those two
things the fantasy and also the gambling
show I kind of want some of your input
what did we like about the fantasy
league last year shout out to meatloaf
Henry for running that and making it
possible do we want to do it on Yahoo do
we still want to do it on ESPN do we not
like some of the scoring
we don't was 400 people I want to do it
again I think it's really really fun
it'll just be me drafted maybe we'll get
ingmar in it too and then we'll figure
out the co-hosts too but when do we want
to have the draft I'm gonna hit up
meatloaf Henry and see if he wants to do
it again if not I might need one of you
guys to run it
I loved how we had some videos during
the year it's fantasy is a commitment so
I appreciate that but we are definitely
definitely definitely gonna do the left
go show fantasy league may just call it
the LFS left go fit that doesn't make
sense
LFL left go fantasy league I actually
want to call it something about the 33%
so it might be the 3 3 FL the 33%
fantasy league which I think would be
really cool and then in terms of the
gambling show I don't have sims to
battle this year so again I'm hoping to
have somebody on here for the gambling
show but I also want you guys to be
involved during the season for that show
that comes out on Fridays and I kind of
want to compete with you guys so I do
not know the best way to do that the
fantasy league it's easy we sign up for
a fantasy league they're scoring one guy
kind of oversees the whole league it
makes sense but if you guys have any
ideas on how to keep track of a big Doc
or something like that where everyone
makes their predictions or if there is
an app or a website that like um it's
not like a pick'em because we have to
also allocate money like because I
wanted to be like what you guys saw us
to where it's like I want to bet 500 on
this game and 200 on that game I still
think I want to do that so if you guys
have any ideas
hit me up slide into the Instagram DMS
at Adam left ko lef koe man no man and
and kind of shoot me the ideas and I
want to bet against you guys I want to
be the only show where I'm competing
with my listeners the 33% to see I would
love if I lost like it 400 of you beat
me and could bet on games better than me
which I'm sure you can I would love that
I don't know if I'm doing left ko locks
this year if I'm not doing it officially
will bleach report I'll do it with the
podcast account we'll do it with the
Instagram it'll be great but hit me up I
always want to
prove this so that it's more and more
fun and easier to do 33% oh I'm not
getting emotional I just can't talk
I appreciate you with all my heart I
cannot wait to announce the show and
what its gonna be called and all the
cool elements that are gonna be a part
of it I cannot wait to announce the
co-hosts that we're gonna have for
during the season it's gonna be great
and I really think you're gonna like
more and more of these interviews I mean
shoot we're gonna have Vince Carter
coming up on an episode got him out
there who knew Vince Carter was a huge
Tampa Bay Bucs fan I did we're gonna get
into it so 33% you are the [ __ ] man if
you would hit that music back there so
we can wrap this bad boy up I'm on the
road for Cooper rating my voice and
getting ready to make some awesome
content for you a 33% I love you I am
the lef koe man and we will holla holla
holla at you another time be good guys
[Music]